here we go
in three
two
one the movie of the summer ah heck the
year top gun maverick has hit theaters
and the fans are slayed with all the
action thrills and shirtless men hello
shimmying miles teller here's a look at
some behind the scenes fun from top gun
too maverick that's what topkin's been
doing for years making grown men cry
number one if you were a fan gripping
your seat watching the cast fly high in
their jets and wondering how they make
that look so real well we've got some
news for you the cast was really flying
after months of training like actual men
and women in the navy when it came to
the stunts on planes the actors were
dropped from sestas and free-floated in
the air good thing the training dealt
with overcoming the nausea of g-force
during flight training they would be
embarrassed about puking in fact while
tom cruise loved flying he even used his
own plane in one scene miles teller
tells a different story of sure it was
fun but also terrifying good thing miles
has his mustache to keep him safe
number two while the training the actors
had to go through was grueling and
grueling is an understatement what most
people do not realize is if you fly in a
plane you have to know how to swim in
the sea the purpose of the training is
in the event that there were an
over-the-water emergency the military
makes sure that you understand that if
things aren't going well in the sky one
will have to be ejected from the plane
and you will most likely land underwater
therefore the actors were thrown into
pools of water and twisted and flipped
every which way you could possibly be
thrown into a tub of water we bet when
these actors thought about method acting
they never realized waterboarding would
be the method used number three while
there are many a rumor spreading about
top gun 2 maverick mostly that it's
awesome one rumor that has gone through
the broken telephone wires is that there
was zero use of cgi in the movie while
the plane flying is totally real the
explosions
not so much anything to do with bombs
exploding or guns going off were in fact
cgi due to safety factors and why any
decision in movie making is made money
it made more logistical sense to cgi up
the missiles but fans of practical
effects take solace that tom cruise's
hair all real baby number four most film
buffs know that tom cruise loves and we
assume demands to do his own stunts but
he took his stunt performing up a notch
on top gun 2 maverick when he designed
an all-encompassing aviation training
for his fellow actors allowing tom to
teach in a case of helping him helping
you jerry maguire anyone help me
help you not only allowing the actors to
learn but made them admire tom in a
whole new light showing them not only
how to fly but how to withstand the
g-force that comes with the fallout of
high-impact jet flying we don't think it
matters what kind of student you were if
tom cruise is your teacher attendance
would be perfect
number five even if you haven't seen the
first top gun odds are you know the
volleyball scene
let's go the scene that launched a
thousand libidos and made you
definitively realize if you liked boys
is a camp classic and cannot be touched
that being said until you see the beach
football scene in top gun 2 maverick
sure it can't beat the original val
kilmer hubba hubba but withhold your
comments until you see a shimmying miles
teller shirtless and smirking and then
tell me which scene is the fairest in
all the land however get ready to feel
bummed about your body because all those
shirtless beauties filmed that scene
once and then were given the note to
reshoot it because to quote tom cruise
the bodies weren't doing it for him the
first time around so the boys went back
to the gym for two weeks and beefed up
number six top gun two maverick is so
technology forward that even val
kilmer's speaking voice has benefited
from the advancement of technology
tragically in 2015 actor vel kilmer was
diagnosed with throat cancer after
several life-saving procedures kilmer's
voice has sadly been reduced to a rasp
however fans and tom cruise alike needed
the iceman to come back to the danger
zone the sequel just wouldn't be the
same without kilmer so through ai
technology and the ai company sonantic
they were able to use snippets of audio
from other vel kilmer movies and create
the talking voice heard in top gun 2.
now i can express myself again
i can bring these dreams to you an
emotional and touching scene this step
in technology could mean so much for
actors who may have lost their voice due
to illness
is something wrong
no number seven this movie was years in
the making every decision-making moment
was a thought-out brainstorming session
between director joseph kaczynski tom
cruise and jerry bruckheimer when
deciding who would get the role of
goose's son rooster goose played by er
alum anthony edwards tom cruise and
jerry bruckheimer were team glenn powell
with classic hollywood looks and
old-time hollywood charm a casting
decision making powell the star seems
like a no-brainer however director
joseph kaczynski held out hope for his
number one draft pick of miles teller
teller was an established actor and
independent movie darling and definitely
the underdog pick to lead a blockbuster
franchise
however when teller came in to read for
the part the chemistry between cruz and
teller was undeniable throw in the fact
that director kaczynski photoshopped a
mustache onto teller's face to seal the
deal
number eight sure we've repeated it more
times than necessary but darn it if it
ain't impressive that top gun uses
mostly practical effects however the
reasoning for having actual air force
jets flying through the skies as opposed
to cgi is a little bit very political
the department of defense entertainment
media office loaned out the planes to
the crew of top gun in order to allow
them to use real planes and not go out
of pocket now this isn't the first time
the military has been a part of
blockbuster movies in fact the
department of defense entertainment
media office was created in the 80s upon
the making of the academy award best
picture-winning movie wings
number nine we all know and love the
original beach volleyball scene in top
gun and we now all simp for the beach
football scene of top gun 2 maverick
however these scenes according to tom
cruise aren't just in the movies for the
audience to giggle and wiggle at tom
cruise claims there is a deep important
narrative behind showing these scenes
tom stated first of all it shows that to
fighter pilots physical prowess is very
important plus the scene shows the
constant competition between these guys
how they compete on every level number
10 top gun maverick is a story about
family and sons and while the touching
tale tells the story of anthony edwards
and miles teller as father son there
actually was another actor in the cast
with a famous papa louis pullman bob in
maverick is actually the son of actor
bill pullman bill pullman known for such
movies as while you were sleeping and
independence day also has flown a jet in
a movie as the president in independence
day bill pullman's character flew an
fa-18 hornet well
his stunt devil did but unlike father
sun actually flew the fa-18 improving on
the sins of the father so to speak
number 11. in the world of movies actors
sometimes have the ability to influence
the writing and vice versa for actor
miles teller he was given the honor to
create his character's nickname or call
sign of rooster it made both literal
sense that his character would go by
rooster since it's a bird and bird's fly
and that it has ties to the first movie
where teller's character is the son of
the fan favorite goose wait a second
this is actually kind of cool number 12
the original top gun was directed by the
prolific and genius tony scott known for
such movies as the original top gun true
romance and man on fire tony scott was
the obvious choice to direct maverick
however after scott's untimely death in
2010 the movie that had been under
development with tom cruise and jerry
brookheimer was put on hold for five
years pausing a snag in a movie that was
already proving difficult to lift off
the ground then if you count the delay
of the pandemic it's a miracle audiences
are currently sitting in theaters
enjoying all that top gun 2 has to offer
this day is for you and i just can't
wait to see it number 13. well most
actors in hollywood would kill to be in
a blockbuster movie let alone a movie
with a built-in fan base and a legacy
some actors actually turned down a
chance to be in top gun 2 maverick
stranger things actor matthew modine
said uh thanks but no thanks for the
chance to play a role in the tom cruise
action-packed plane movie claiming he
didn't agree with the movie's politics
number 14. top gun 2 maverick was the
most hotly anticipated movie of the year
and dare we say years after announcing
that it would be released in 2019
marking 33 years since the original film
took off the movie had to be bumped due
to the practical effects taking their
time to make everything look um freaking
amazing and while that hold on releasing
the film was expected to push it into
2020 something called a global pandemic
upended everyone and everything suddenly
made releasing top gun 2
take your breath away challenge however
finally after almost 3 years of
lockdowns vaccines and masks the sequel
was ready for liftoff here's hoping the
next movie the franchise takes less time
than 36 years to hit theaters
number 15 the original concept for the
original top gun happened to be inspired
by a magazine article reported by
california magazine in 1983 by eugene
the article followed the day-to-day
lives of fighter pilots at naval air
station miramar in san diego and just
like the movie this article shouted out
fun call sign nicknames as well in the
original movie call signs like maverick
merlin and iceman were used in the film
whereas in the article the pilots and
commanders had nicknames such as yogi
gringo gator and possum
we're assuming after watching this video
you're either mid cold shower or already
buying tickets to see top gun 2 maverick
again which behind the scenes moment
took your breath away like comment and
subscribe to the things for all things
miles towers mustache and more